apple's new m2 max have finally been
revealed including the totally
redesigned macbook air which i am
extremely excited to get my hands on and
start testing but over the past week
we've been getting more and more leaks
and rumors about apple's upcoming macs
for the rest of this year and even
getting into early next year so in this
video i'm gonna share all of those brand
new leaks and when they are gonna be
coming and i'm gonna be putting a bunch
of puzzle pieces together including
older leaks which perfectly add up to
these new ones so with that said let's
get right into it now you might remember
earlier this year when apple registered
three new macs in the eurasian database
ahead of their march event and according
to the actual filing there was one new
laptop product and two new desktop macs
which one of those ended up being the
mac studio with a model number
a2615 but unfortunately we didn't see
those other two models get released
until this month yes one of those was
the m2 macbook air which was the sole
laptop within those filings which we
think is a two six 8 1. now yes apple
did also release the m2 macbook pro but
because it uses the same exact chassis
and no design change it actually does
not require a new eec filing because
those filings are only for new chassis
designs so that basically leaves us with
a2 686 which is a desktop mac which
apple has still not released yet and in
my opinion that is the m2 mac mini and
the main reason i believe this is
because back in march mark german
actually tweeted that apple was testing
the m2 chip which we just got but he
also said that a new mac mini is ready
to go and it could also launch soon
while at the same time saying that the
imac pro and mac pro is not shipping
soon and even after the event he tweeted
again in april saying that apple is
testing nine new m2 based macs including
a new m2 mac mini and since we already
got two out of those three eec filing
mac models including the mac studio and
the m2 macbook air i believe that coming
this fall potentially in october or
november apple is going to be releasing
the redesigned mac mini and the reason i
believe that is because i think apple is
limiting their redesigns or new designs
to one per event so only one new design
per event which is the key to how apple
is releasing their new products so let
me explain why well last year starting
in april apple released their m2 imac
and they just focused on that imac alone
because it was a new design then fall
2021 they released their new macbook pro
designs the 14 and 16 inch then in march
they released the soul mac studio and
then in june they released the macbook
air redesign while also giving us the
same m2 macbook pro design so i think
they could have released the m2 mac mini
at the wwdc event but they chose not to
because they would have two brand new
redesigns in the same event which they
don't want to do they want to have the
spotlight on one redesign at a time so
with that said that's why i think the m2
mac mini is going to be coming this fall
now let's move on to the rest of the
apple lineup that we should expect just
the other day mark grumman gave us
another bombshell leaked report saying
that the m2 pro max macbook pros could
come as soon as the end of this year or
early next year and not only that he's
expecting a 15-inch macbook air for next
year and apple is also working on a new
12-inch laptop so before i break all of
that down the first thing i want to talk
about is the 15-inch macbook air which
is going to be
absolutely insane well first of all ross
young replied to mark's tweet and he
said that the 15-inch macbook air is
gonna have a
15.2 inch display which basically
implies that it's also gonna have a
notch which totally makes sense now you
might think it's weird for apple to make
a 15 inch macbook air but i actually
think it's genius because i believe
apple is pushing their iphone lineup
strategy over to their macbooks for
example if you've been following the
leaks for the iphone 14 lineup there
should be a regular iphone 14 and a 14
max which has identical specs but with a
larger size and display while at the
same time having a 14 pro and then a 14
pro max which has the same specs but
again a larger display for a more
expensive price and as you can see right
here in my tweet i believe apple is
doing that with a 13 and 15 inch macbook
air with a lower price so the same specs
just a larger size with more battery
life and then they have the higher end
lineup which is the 14 and 16 inch
macbook pro with the higher price but
identical specs and i actually ended up
asking ross young about this idea saying
that it's going to be basically the same
situation as the 14 16 inch macbook pro
identical specs larger size and he said
yes from a display standpoint as far as
i know so he kind of agrees with that in
terms of the display and according to
mark german he believes that the 15-inch
macbook air could be released in early
2023 at a planned spring event which
basically points to it having identical
specs to the current new macbook air but
with that larger size but now it's time
to move on to the crazy 12-inch macbook
that apple is working on and literally
the day after mark german's report about
the 12-inch macbook we got another huge
leak saying that the 12-inch macbook
could come with an m2 pro and m2 max
chip launching at the end of 2023
or early in 2024 which kind of points to
it coming with an m3 chip however
literally the day after mark german's
report about the 12-inch macbook we got
another leak saying that it could come
with an m2 pro or m2 max chip option
which sounds absolutely insane and this
leak actually came from imagine boo on
twitter and this is what he said it's
gonna get released in 2023 and he
doesn't know the processor yet but it is
supposed to be equipped with m2 pro and
m2 max suggesting that it could join the
new 14 and 16 inch macbook pro lineup
now to me that sounds absolutely insane
but majin buu has actually been correct
quite a bit check this out only a few
days ago he made a leak saying that
apple is developing a new 14.1 inch ipad
m2 with 512 gigs of storage and 16 gigs
of base memory and then it's supposed to
be joining the 11-ish model with no
major changes and a new 12.9 inch model
with reduced bezels and the crazy thing
about imagine boost leak is that ross
young came out the next day confirming
that the 14.1 inch ipad pro is being
developed saying that early 2023 may be
more likely in terms of the timing so he
confirmed imagine boost leak which is
awesome because ross young was totally
correct about the 13.6 inch m2 macbook
air display size and not only that but
mark german came out and agreed with
ross young and majin buu saying that
there could be a 14.1 inch ipad pro
which he has leaked way earlier in terms
of apple making a new larger size ipad
but in my opinion i think it actually
makes more sense for this new 12-inch
macbook to come with an m3 chip instead
because those m1 pro and max chips use a
ton of power and they get very hot even
the 14 inch was already thermal
throttling so i can't see apple putting
an empty pro or m2 max into a 12 inch
but now let's get into the last mac that
we could be expecting this year and that
is the mac pro going back to mark
german's tweet from april 14th he said
that apple is testing at least nine new
m2 based macs including a mac pro so
let's jump right into those leaks as we
all know apple gave us a very
interesting teaser at their march event
listen up making our transition nearly
complete with just one more product to
go mac pro the mac pro so what he's
talking about is the apple silicon
transition because in june of 2020 apple
announced that it will take them two
years to transition all of their macs
over to apple silicon and that
transition ends in november because that
is when they first announced the m1 max
so two years after that is november of
2022 so my prediction is that this
november we have an apple event where
apple reveals and launches the mac pro
and i think it's going to start shipping
in december so here's a little bit of
evidence for that prediction back in
march imagineboo made a crazy leak where
he said that there is going to be a new
2022 mac pro and the processor code name
is red fern and he at the time thought
it was going to be coming in september
but i think it makes more sense to come
in december and he showed off the ultra
fusion links that apple is going to be
using to connect four different dyes so
this is a crazy leak that he showed off
and i believe it's true and i believe
it's coming because many months ago on
january 2nd 2022
mark german actually said that he
expected apple to finish announcing its
transition to its own silicon from intel
chips as early as june at wwdc
now that did not happen so i think we
are going to see that finish out later
this year in november and mark german
certainly agrees and not only that but
ross young has been leaking a new
27-inch mini led pro studio display
which he thought was going to get
announced in june alongside a new mac
pro which he said yes that is our
thinking but later he came out and said
that it has been delayed due to the
shanghai lockdowns and that production
is being moved to a different location
saying that it could be an october
release and that is why i believe apple
didn't say anything about the mac pro at
wwdc
because they wanted to release this new
display alongside the mac pro and
because of that i think apple is holding
off and they're going to wait until
november so that was a huge video
hopefully you guys enjoyed it and if you
disagree with any of my thoughts comment
them down below but if you enjoyed the
video click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check one out right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video